warning this game contains scenes of a
severe violence and gore if you didn't
know that already you haven't been
paying to detention at all oh this is
rage I wasn't paying attention either
I just looked over hello everybody my
name is markiplier and this is don't
whack your teacher this one you really
need to pay attention to the title
because the dolt is right in there
before the whack so don't lack anything
at all this is just a stress reliever
for your everyday life and this was
extremely requested by you guys also I
am very tired also I'm not in my
apartment I'm not anywhere that you guys
have ever seen in your entire life
before and you don't know what this is
in anyway or wherever this is actually
an entirely new setup for me so I gotta
pay attention to something or not let's
go for me scuse me you want to run that
by me again sir Oh only available at
that website book picture for nerds as I
vow not deadly though
he's not dead he's just crying I guess
that's a good thing I mean please don't
finish him off this is a terrible game
it's such a bad role model oh those bees
oh my goodness oh he's not dead yes he's
horrible bees everywhere
oh god I'm loopy as hell oh really
really no I thought he was gonna do with
the pratfall out the window Oh Oh
outside just really I just realized that
this is the same kid as in black the
thief oh this poor poor poor town
haunted by the demon it's testing this
kill come on okay then that hurt kid no
you can mute the pain crackle cord oh
why do you guys want to see this why do
I want to see this all of his teeth were
piano that chair into society killings
you oh I guess teachers are just the
bosses of the children these days but no
stress reliever not this is not always
so nice oh yay what is that lighter oh
it's so horrible why am i laughing hey
why does he blob Oh cuz he tossed the
spray can over at felon explain why blow
up like that that an air pump was that a
pesticide spray why would there be
either of those in that's a pesticide
sprayer why is that in a why oh no it's
the scene from men in black just for
good making in case the poison I
injected in your feet wasn't good enough
oh he's still alive good he's still
alive in all of these you guys need to
remember that oh no no no whoa you
scoundrel leaving this one he's still
alive he's still alive he's gonna be
fine it wasn't like whack your boss when
it was just a gouge of blood everywhere
and everywhere Oh stapler time why he's
still alive somehow the coffee thermos
yeah trip you little prick the sadistic
joint are we so concerned all yours
consign for you
still alive so I oh boy
you want to see really Oh what was that
this is an example of what's wrong with
society today huh okay that's all for
don't whack your teacher listen listen
let me let me just have a talk with you
don't do that don't don't do that
don't no no so I think that's all of the
don't whack yours or whack yours of
whack your whatever games I think I'm
done even if there's more I don't think
I'd like to play them they're gruesome
and horrible and all they do is make me
cringe and they put out a bad message
for the kids today it's not good
television so thank you all so much for
watching
if for some reason you'd like to see
other people get brutally murdered on a
cartoony backdrop then click the
annotations are looking at description
down there I'm very tired I'm gonna go
take a nap
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye well s is mean